[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff passen from the mothership ESPN
senior Baseball Insider joining us from
Scottsdale Arizona Jeff good to have you
on where do you want to start with the
rule chain the the one rule change that
you think will have the biggest change
in baseball is going to be what
I think that the pitch clock
is going to be the biggest change in
Major League Baseball perhaps to
integration
Mike I I I don't feel like I'm being a
prisoner of the moment in saying that I
just look back at all the rules changes
throughout the years and I don't know
that I can find one that's going to have
as demonstrable an effect on the game as
the pitch clock does because you're
right like they're a great three-hour
movies and they're a terrible two and a
half hour movies but I think there's a
psychological barrier that fans have
erected in their minds about baseball
where it's too long
it's too slow it's to insert negative
connotative adjective right there and I
don't I don't know if you have a chance
to watch any of the Minor League games
last year where the pitch clock was used
uh I'm telling you Dan if you haven't
seen a baseball game with a pitch clock
once you do you're gonna be like how in
the hell did they go this long without
it
um it's you know people at Major League
Baseball like to say this is going to
bring the game back to the style from
the 70s and 80s that we had not just
where stolen bases are more emphasized
but where the game feels crisp and clean
and even quick which is something you
would never say about Modern Baseball
um in in two and a half hour games I
think are going to be regular
occurrences but beyond the time of game
itself it's just gonna be the pace of it
they're just cutting out dead high in
the game they're cutting the time that
the pitcher's standing there on the
mound looking in for signals and shaking
and holding and trying to mess up the
hitters timing They're Gonna Keep
hitters accountable and inside the
batter's box they have to be there when
the clock hits eight looking at the
pitcher ready for a pitch to be
delivered I I think the closest fact
simile I can make is that every game is
going to look like a Mark Burley game
now and if you remember Mark Burley was
the quickest pitcher in the big leagues
for a long time and his games were fun
to watch because you knew he was going
to get the ball in his glove be right on
the mound already come set and get ready
to pitch within 12 to 15 seconds and
that is going to be everyone now it's
going to take a lot of time in spring
training and even in April for guys to
get used to this but I think once they
do the effect on the game is going to be
enormous and enormously positive why
bigger bases
um
because they want them to look more like
pizza boxes I mean I you know I no I I
think I think in reality there's a
twofold element to it one is the hope
that it will cut down on injury you know
guys first base getting stepped on but I
think the more demonstrable effect is
that they want to increase stolen basis
we are at a point now in baseball where
the players are
infinitely more talented than they were
50 years ago and that's that's not to
suggest that guys in the 70s weren't
good they just weren't educated like
players are now on how to take this
craft and come as close to perfecting it
as you can they they weren't training
like the way that players are now so you
have more speed right now and you have
fans who love stolen bases because of
course they love so on bases it's an
exciting Play It's essentially mono
Amano with the catcher in the runner and
the runner is trying to uh out Fox The
Catcher And it's something that we've
done as kids throughout all you know
throughout our existence can I beat
something to a point can I get there
faster than it can and when you cut down
I know it's only four and a half inches
but considering it's such a bang bang
play every time it's second and third
base if those four and a half inches
could make all the difference in the
world well I don't think Ricky
Henderson's record is in jeopardy
anytime soon I do think someone's gonna
steal 75 bases this year and it's been a
long long time since we've seen that
gosh when was the last time we had
somebody steal that many bases
I should probably know this but
unfortunately I'm too far from my see
normally like this is why radio
interviews before Zoom were so wonderful
because I can see you could Google just
type it up and no one would know because
I could type softly and then I sound
smart now I sound like a bumbling idiot
who just doesn't know who lasts those 75
bases so please someone hit baseball
reference for us all right let's uh
Paulie you want to give us some
suggestions of who could be the last
player to have at least 75. Well Ricky
Henderson is at 1406 stolen base no but
who stole 75 bases in a season most
recently yes that was the question D
Gordon Maybe
oh no I was asking you for the answer
Jacoby Ellsbury hit 70 in 2009
that was the last year he was good right
is he still getting paid by the Yankees
by the way
Yankees wins over that much I know Annie
Lofton in 96 hit 75. yeah man
yeah let's put it this way it's been a
while and I it was very interesting to
me Major League Baseball made a
presentation out here a couple days ago
and they did one in Florida yesterday
where they were sort of uh you know
assessing the state of the game and in
this assessment of the state of the game
they they're talking about what fans
want they did they said they did a big
wide-ranging survey and nowhere on there
was home runs which surprised me a
little bit even with the proliferation
of home runs I still think fans love
them but stolen bases was at like the
top of the list and uh I get it you know
the I I think sewing bases are a
microcosm of where Major League Baseball
has gone and maybe where it's aired
which is that they realized unless you
steal bases at a 75 to 80 clip it's just
not a smart thing to run and so that
kind of phased out the you know the
trying to make baseball so efficient uh
it phase out solar cases and this really
is an effort to bring back that lost
part of the game
we're talking to Jeff passen from the
mothership uh the shift that uh well no
more shifts now you have to have two
fielders on the left side of the infield
in two infielders and you have to stay
on the dirt uh who is going to benefit
from this
uh theoretically the left-handed hitters
who were losing out on what would have
been singles to right field but you have
the third baseman shifted all the way
over to to short right field or you move
the second baseman over and move
everyone else over that's who it should
help um I'm not sure that singles up in
the middle are going to make quite the
comeback that that people are thinking
or hoping because remember you can still
have the shortstop shifted over to one
step to the right of second base or the
second baseman shifted over to to one
step of the left uh but I I do think
that those
oh I think the freeze up there another
thing that never happened on the prison
yeah when you did radio yeah when you're
on your cell phone didn't freeze up
let's see if we got him back Jeff do we
have you back I think I'm back there
there you are I think I'm here I help
I'm here yeah but but you said
left-handed hitters are probably going
to benefit more
yeah left-handed pull power hitters guys
who were Dr you know dropping balls into
into right field all the shift rules are
going to change Dan is I'm just gonna
have singles back to the game so I'm not
sure how exciting like you know
marginally hard hit line drives into
right field but take one hop and go to
the right field there are necessarily I
know the shift has been an issue that
has caused enormous consternation among
older Baseball fans and you know people
who even though it's been around since
Ted Williams uh bemoan the fact that
Defenders are shifted but the fact that
it's only really going to add singles
back to the party I just don't think
it's going to have that huge in effect
nowhere close to the pitch block frankly
I think the the pick-off rule where you
can only disengage from the rubber twice
which means either two pick-off moves
Two Step offs or some combination
they're in uh may have a greater effect
on the game than the shift yeah I was
wondering about that let's say you throw
over twice I I can take whatever lead I
want now because you can't throw over
right well you can throw over a third
time you can throw over a third time but
if the guy isn't out if he gets back to
the base in time then it's considered a
buck and he gets to advance and anyone
else on base gets to advance as well uh
great to talk to you have fun out there
in spring training thank you Jeff